[Music]
in Jungle Book News submitted by Ashley
a fan from Barbados Barbados isn't that
where we AMA is from yeah yeah a man who
was raised by wolves is disappointed by
life among humans of course you a man is
[ __ ] confining out here dude in the
real world raised by wolves yeah does
that mean can't even speak English or
does he speak how so when he's hit in
the city he's like his butt starts
shaking
[ __ ] scratches here with his feet I
know that's that'd be [ __ ] crazy I
wants to see that yeah so this man named
Marcos has a crush on a girl pisses on
her I wouldn't honestly though if
somebody was raised by wolves I wouldn't
be surprised if that's what they need to
show affection really wouldn't it's like
you have an interesting smelling [ __ ]
in her leg I'm sorry I'm just horny yeah
yeah also if you hump somebody's I
didn't pick up somebody you just say I
was raised by wolves I really want a
hump or vagina but your leg was just
there first so yeah so Marcos he lived
among wolves for 12 years
damn and this takes place in Spain so he
speaks Spanish and so uh so you hung out
with Spanish wolves yeah those guys are
romantic yeah romantic wolves soon as he
said that I saw the wolves sitting like
this they'd [ __ ] lay cross yeah so
this man is now 72 years old but he was
born in 1946 he lost his mom when he was
only three years old soon after his
father abandoned him to live with
another woman in the neighboring town
but then he was taken to a sheep herder
in the mountains and he was tasked to
look over look after 300 sheep and so
obviously when he was a three-year-old
looking over sheep
maybe a little maybe like a six-year-old
or something probably do that so he
knows enough human [ __ ] reason why I'm
asking you because like there are people
that have been raised by wolves
since like a baby oh damn and they don't
have any human like yeah it was a great
case study for like nature versus
nurture and they can't function or learn
language or learn effective past that
stage when a when a child can absorb all
those skills you can't ever go back yeah
yeah ooh all that development make their
brain yeah yeah you know that makes
girls okay yeah so then uh once he went
to that old sheep herder then the sheep
herder died when he was eight years old
his poor baby three hundred four things
to play with well we think this is
shitty right but he's looking at us like
you don't know how fun it's more [ __ ]
up yeah so before the old man died he
did teach him how to make fire and use
various tools but then when it was in
1954 that's when the dude died leaving
him alone and then it's not really known
exactly how Markos wound up living with
wild wolves in the mountains but he did
and he lived with them for 12 years
until the Civil Guard found him and by
the time they found him he had already
replaced human words or spoken words
with grunts and you guys know that huh
over there that just sounds like a chola
speaking
without placed human words with crooks
he's just Mexican like RT we huh she she
doesn't like [ __ ] Rick Ross or dice
pineapples
I had a phase where I did a rick ross
grunt after a lot of things it was
everybody has why are you look at me
like that
actually burped and you didn't notice I
was like yeah no I
I thought the noise he made was pretty
cool so like I would do it yeah it was
look I see the disapproval in your face
- yeah cuz it's [ __ ] Rick Ross huh
yeah sounds cool though like Rick Ross
is like to me he's like the phoniest
[ __ ] on earth did you take
freeway [ __ ] Ricky's name right you
are a [ __ ] prison guard yeah and now
you're a [ __ ] tough [ __ ] on out here
dude I would never say to your face but
he's a he's a prison guard and he's
rapping about that thought he was a
gangster no he was a prison guard I like
the eye but I still think he's a
gangster I like that dice pineapple song
yeah all this stuff he was on the
Suicide Squad soundtrack games I think
as a prison guard he learned about all
these gang stories and then use it as
motivation in his music so he's a great
portrayer I think he's a great artist
now back to Marco's here at one point he
tried to go live with the Wolves again
cuz he just did not like life with
humans but by the time that he tried to
go back to the wolves it wasn't the same
anymore in the Wolves no longer saw him
as a brother because it's a different
pack she smelled like human oh yes you
smell like the cities' my clothes who
are you oh that's so beautiful but so
sad at the end we like do when you smell
like pee like us
yeah cuz he says that like you could
tell that they were right there that he
could hear them panting and like he
would call out to them but they they
don't they wouldn't approach him because
he felt like a person how long was he
away from like his pack after that I
don't know they don't mention like how
much time went on from when like he was
first taken to when he tried to go back
but I mean this dude it's 70 what is he
72 now and he lived with them for 12
years from when he was 8 so that means
he was around 20 and then maybe he
integrated back into being a human
I would imagine like you know wolves and
dogs don't live as long as humans right
so like they might was pretty aging
really bad or like or like you know or
by the time it's a whole new group or I
don't know yeah they wouldn't remember
him anymore
also it's kind of sad that he was just
like looking for somebody accept him for
his whole life and then he tries to go
back to his pack that he thinks will
accept him yeah they turn him away - I
want to hear this guy's full story I'm
so interested in just you should make a
movie about him what's his name like
Antonio or something
Marco's Michael Rodriguez pantoja I
wanted to pee on everything but they
wouldn't let me know what the finally I
know I was really sick is he saying that
they've tied him how to survive in the
wild they showed him which berries and
mushrooms - we're safe to eat and and
then which ones were poisonous that's
cool
yeah they would teach him all that and
then he remember sleeping in caves among
bats snakes and deer and running
barefoot on rough terrain without a care
in the world
and that he would only wrap his feet up
when they hurt because of the snow but
that he had such big calluses on his
feet that kicking a rock was like
kicking a ball that's what our feet are
supposed to be like we're supposed to
have really thick calluses yeah like
hooves yeah yeah I mean humans aren't
meant to have shoes like the pads of a
dog you know dog pads are like hella
rough hmm I can't do that I like my feet
soft yeah I like getting pedicures and
stuff yeah yeah I like the different
colors I
except for well I like getting pedicures
until they start taping my feet and [ __ ]
and then I get rhythm it's a pinky total
touchdowns like I'm like stubo really
like the center of your feet they don't
get you there no yeah sometimes I think
they just like the mess with me and they
just keep rubbing my feet yeah no I
compared my cat's paws to Casey's
family's cats that they're actually a
mistake Casey's feet no no these
families cats and Dallas and those
obviously because they're outdoors are
like wings and then my cats are like a
princess pause because they're pinned or
they're all soft and pink yeah they are
they're super soft they're so soft that
I even set up my my thumbprint thing on
my iphone to my cat's paw thing cuz it
actually works yes it works so every
time you want to check your phone you
gotta like well we're like fun of you
wanted to did he say about anything
about like why he doesn't like humans
and like why he doesn't like so they
briefly go over at least in this article
he said that he talks about being
cheated and abused by his fellow man
exploited by bosses in the hospitality
and construction business and laughed at
by his peers because he doesn't know
much about things like soccer and
politics so he just feels really
heartbroken that like his fellow man and
treating my judged yeah but then the
wolves like they wouldn't do that hard
okay
I mean that's not healthy bar Madhu's my
foot really sad yeah he had a [ __ ]
hard
yeah it did that's a Flyers jacket broke
it is oh that him ago wolf crazy cuz
like you can't I don't know what that's
that's dope community was able to live
with fools God look at the size of that
animal though
and they're odorless which is stuff yeah
and their purse so crazy it's just like
thick and like it's not like a dog's fur
not even class like when ours
when I was a I was watching on YouTube
like those wolf you know people who like
are integrated with wolves and you see a
wolf jump up on a man and he's like his
height and I was like a wolf Glick my
face oh really yeah
good throw love that sounds dangerous no
it was like it no it's either you know
most of those wolves they're not a
hundred percent the one that we we saw a
lot of them woods or yet they're all
dogs but that they're so wild I read
earlier a whoop is an apex predator yep
it is either and they'll eat you apex
Matthew that's right that's right
I don't like whoa like I I'm like oh
they're cool but I like dogs
daddy goes things right no no I like I
like them but for me like not the way
people fantasize about them like oh I'm
gonna be my spear animalism you mean
looks like butt plug status I'm like
yeah you don't even know the true like
craziness of a wolf like I'd rather just
have a song I'm like dogs are cool you
know dogs are more complex
I like cocker spaniels and Shiba inus
that's what I like yeah and I think
wolves are like that's the wrong doggy
dog just everything about you is just so
[ __ ] opposite like you're this
big-ass dude and you want the [ __ ]
small well I grew up with a cocker
spaniel and when he died I cried a lot
so that's why Congress paddles are dead
their GU but look at his [ __ ]
monstrous size he wants a Mini Cooper he
wants some [ __ ] I don't want a Mini
Cooper I defended Steve's choice in the
Mini Cooper because it's surprisingly
spacious because secure men don't have
to drive and have a little fool yeah my
neighbor to the Sacramento have [ __ ]
pit bull yeah that's true that bulls are
so pretty I feel like if I see a guy
with a motorcycle and a pit bull like
you're compensating not like seriously
why got it look so hard the only reason
why I don't like is because they
scoobert so huge big dogs have become
when they play dude they're [ __ ]
strong man there's solid
I like wrestling a thick ass doctor to
buy them and they won't cry they feel
more sturdier than any dog that I've
ever felt like when you pet a pitbull
like so there's a peple named Steve
wasn't my pet pit bull but the person
that owned the house like this way from
us they abandoned this little pit bull
and I was like feeding it to take care
of it and I took it in just until like
we could give it up to another family
but that dog was so like friendly but
when I would pet it I was like smack it
in the butt and it would have feel it's
a thick dog cause it's nice and thick
and muscular yeah it's like a
bodybuilder [ __ ] yeah yeah that dog
was [ __ ] is so cute it's like a baby -
it's like forever baby face it was like
it was like that caramel brown and that
white patchy color so it's [ __ ] I
like statue pitbulls little spots all
over the place I want a beagle beagles
are cool I like beagles to me holes are
cool they just howl too much for me
[Music]
you
[Music]